A monster has appeared
[Music] [
Music]
What
do you mean, Ryota-san? You
can't defeat Guts Slime by yourself. What do you mean? When a
slime is near
death, it becomes invincible. It
doesn't take damage from the last person it attacked.  Does that mean we
need someone to play the role of fishermen and the role of finishing blow? Reminiscing about the
ban on solos.
Leave this rare episode to us.
Ryota is the best in the finishing role.
[Music]
[Applause] I'll
do the final blow.
[Music]
Successful.  Well, if we all defeat it, it's
not that strong of an opponent. I
like onions. All I need is carrots. Well
then, tonight I'll
make curry. It's a curry with potatoes, onions, and carrots.
Rolling carrots. That's
good.
Dangerous.
Carrots are fine.  Is it a
rare monster that is different from "Please change its name?"
Self and how to defeat this one is a delivery
slime. It requires the same finishing touch, but when it
goes into invincible mode, it will reflect all the attacks you receive, so be
careful and
don't cut it down carefully.  That's no good.
Leave it to me. I know this guy's HP. I've
done this before before I know it. That's about it.
OK.
[Music]
Teamwork wins. That gem drops. When
equipped, it
reflects some of the attacks.  It's effective. It looks interesting. It
seems like it reflects attacks.
[Music] It's
convenient, but it's faster to attack yourself. As for the
Pe-level carrot, I'll have
Elsa buy this as planned.